there's a new poll from online pollster
yougov conducted for the uh uh The
Economist it shows that with Republicans
Vladimir Putin's favorability rating is
higher than President Obama's and not by
a small margin thirty five percent of
republicans have a favorable view of the
Russian President Vladimir Putin only
nine percent of republicans have a
favorable view of president barack obama
in fairness in September of 2013 Putin
was a viewed more favorably by Democrats
than george w bush I'm sorry of 2003
Putin was viewed more favorably by
Democrats than george w bush the
difference though is that Putin has
actually done insane stuff since then
since 2012 Romney was uh all over Russia
for being a threat the biggest
geopolitical foe etcetera uh and since
then we've seen Russia and Vladimir
Putin actually do a whole bunch of stuff
that we should be really concerned about
right i mean putin fabricated unrest in
crimea and then took the land from
ukraine putin actively opposed American
interest in Syria and sent weapons and
military aid there and of course we
continue to find out about the political
opposition uh in Russia that has been
killed and now the cherry on top
according to the FBI and the CIA Russia
was involved in coordinating hacking in
fake news propaganda to hurt Hillary
Clinton somehow back in twenty twelve
Romney says Russia's the biggest
geopolitical foe Republicans agree now
all of a sudden after Russia actually
does a whole bunch of stuff Republicans
have a more favorable view of lat Amir
Putin than they do a Barack Obama
everything's backwards I feel like well
I don't think it's the prizing cuz i
think vladimir putin is seen as this
authoritarian strong leader alpha male
whereas brock obama has gotten this role
of being considered more weekend you
know willing to back down so the average
republican voter isn't going to know the
nuances and specifics behind russian
policies is treatment behind people who
oppose him journalists so i think it
makes sense and they've been primed by
donald trump to question anything they
hear in media anyway and of course
corporate media is in many ways
cepted corporate media in many ways
present incomplete accounts are profiles
to provide context about stories but
many times the basic story that is
reported on corporate media about what's
going on around the world is generally
true but even those facts are often not
believed by the trumpets because Trump
has done such an effective job at
preparing his supporters do not believe
what they hear on corporate media so uh
that did this is how will this impact
the next four years it's hard to say
exactly but I believe that it will I I
believe that we're already seeing it
number one in terms of the Republican
electorate willingness to tolerate
interactions between the United States
and Russia it would never tolerate
President Obama for example
participating in and that to be
perfectly clear even under george w bush
many Republicans would not have
tolerated Donald Trump has really
achieved something special based on the
people that he appealed to and and the
voters that are responsible for his
electoral win if only by 58,000 elect uh
votes across three states can be very
very interesting for years if if you're
starting off with your pseudo buddy
Putin with a higher favorability rating
than the outgoing president among your
supporters we know that an interesting
four years are coming Warby Parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give you the opportunity to check out
their glasses i personally wear Warby
Parker glasses when I'm not wearing my
contact lenses and I also started with
one of these free at home try ons of
five pairs of glasses you can get your
free home try-on and support the david
pakman show at Warby Parker trial
dot-com / tdps I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick 5
pairs that i liked put them on in the
comfort of my own home pick the one I
like the most and then Warby Parker put
my prescription lenses in there for
a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing